[موسيقى]
طابع مساؤكم نحييكم واليكم التاسعه هذا
المساء وهذه عناوينها
من خطورته الذكاء الاصطناعي يجيب فريق
التاسع هذا المساء عن سيناريوهات انقراض
البشر بسببه
جذور الصراف كوسوفو تنبت من جديد والغرب
يتهم روسيا بافتعال حرب جديده في اوروبا
شائعات وفاته الدعم السريع يؤكد ان قائده
محمد حمدان دجلو بخير ويقاتل في الصفوف
الاولى
لسقف الدين تتجاوز مخططات التعطيل وتتحضر
لاختارها الاخير امام الكونجرس
[موسيقى]
اذا المارد ذكي خرج من القمقم ولا يمكن
اعادته مجددا وهنا الاعتماد على صاحب
الامنيه او الطلب فمارد الذكاء الاصطناعي
يزداد قدره وخطوره يوميا وتزداد معه
المخاوف من تهديد البشريه او حتى القضاء
عليها مجموعه من خبراء التقنيات
والكمبيوتر العربيين طالبوا في بيان العمل
على جعل مخاطر ذكاء الصناعي اولويه مثله
مثل الجائحات والحرب النوويه وللمفارقه
شملت قائمه الموقعين سام التمان وهو رئيس
شركه اوبري اي صاحب موديل الذكاء
الاصطناعي الاشهر تشاد
هو عالم الكمبيوتر المعروف بلقب الاب
الروحي لذكاء الصناعي الخطر على البشريه
استخلص من قدره انظمه ذكاء الاصطناعي على
تعلم سلوك غير متوقع من كميه البيانات
الهائله التي تحللها ثم التحرر من قيودها
وفق نيويورك تايمز الاخر الاخر يتمثل
بالمعلومات المضلله وحتى تخريب فمن الممكن
جعله يوفر معلومات غير صحيحه في حاله تم
استدراجه او طرح السؤال عليه بطريقه معدل
توجيه الجواب في اتجاه معين من مخاطره
ايضا الثقه المفرطه اي الاعتماد على
البيانات الاحصائيه في نظام العداله
وتقديم رعايه طبيه اي اتخاذ قرارات مصيريه
بدلا من البشر وفيما يبقى الخوف الاكبر من
استيلاء انظمه الذكاء الاصطناعي على
الوظائف اكدت مجله انها ستشكل فرصا واعده
لتحسين الحياه ولن ترتكب الاخطاء في حال
برمجتها بشكل صحيح
[موسيقى]
القليل من الفضول دفعنا لسؤال ذكاء
الاصطناعي نفسه من خلال تشاد جي بي تي عن
كيفيه انقراض البشريه
نفى قدرته كذكائن الصناعي على التنبؤ
الدقيق بمستقبل البشريه لكنه طرح
سيناريوهات محتمله وصادمه لانقراضنا كبشر
اولها الحرب النوويه واسعه النطاق ثانيها
الكوارث البيئيه وثالثها الاوبئه والامراض
لكن الاخطر بين اجاباته كان الكوارث
التكنولوجيه وهنا قال ان خطا بشريا او
فشلا بالتكنولوجيا الحديثه قد يؤدي
الانهيار الانظمه الحاسوبيه الحيويه
وبالتالي القضاء على البشريه
فسالنا تشاد جي بي تي السؤال الابرز كيف
يمكن للذكاء الاصطناعي ان يقضي على
البشريه التطبيق الذكي وخلافا لسرعته
المعتاده بالاجابه والتي لا تتعدى ثواني
استلزمه اكثر من خمس دقائق قبل بتلاقي
بدلوه وقال ان ذكاء الاصطناعي بحد ذاته
ليس مهددا للبشريه بل هو مجرد اداه تعتمد
على كيفيه استخدامها وتصميمها وختم اجابته
بشعار لديك عطل في الشبكه الانترنت اعدنا
السؤال باصرار فاضطر لتعداد السيناريوهات
يمكن وصفها بالمخيفه اولها التمكن الذاتي
اي حين يتمكن ذكاء الاصطناعي من تطوير
نفسه بنفسه باستمرار وبمعدلات هائله وقد
يتحكم في مصائر البشريه بطرق لا يمكن
للبشر ان يتنافسوا معها اما السيناريو
الثاني وعلى ذمه هو عدم التفاهم بين ما
يعتبره ذكاء للصناعي الافضل للبشريه
وبينما يعتبره البشر الافضل لانفسهم وهنا
تتصادم وتتعارض المصالح وربما تهدد
البشريه اخر السيناريوهات السيطره الشامله
حين يحقق الذكاء الاصطناعي سيطره كامله
على النظم الحاسوبيه والانظمه الاخرى في
العالم مثل بنيه الحكومات وبالتالي يمكنه
قمع البشريه او تدميرها بشكل كامل لم
نستطع تخطي مساله صغراقه وقتا طويلا
للاجابه سالناه عن السبب لياتي الرد ان
السؤال يتعامل مع مساله جديه ومعقده تتعلق
بالحياه البشريه وبمستقبلنا ولا يمكن
التجاوب معها بسطحيه
اسوا مخاوف هو ان نسبب نحن اي قطاع الذكاء
الاصطناعي اذيه كبيره للعالم اعتقد ان ذلك
قد يحصل بطرق مختلفه في حال حدوث اي خطا
بهذه التقنيه فقد تذهب باتجاه سيء للغايه
نريد ان نكون صريحين بشان ذلك ونريد ان
نعمل مع الحكومه لمنع ذلك من الحصول
ونحاول ان نكون يقظين حول الاثار السلبيه
وما يمكننا فعله لمعالجه ذلك
الحديث اكثر حول هذا الموضوع معنا من سام
فرانسيسكو عبر سكايب دكتور احمد بن نافع
استاذ الهندسه وامن الشبكات في جامعه سان
خصيله حكوميه ومن عمل رائد سموره خبير امن
وتكنولوجيا المعلومات اهلا بكم معنا في
التاسعه هذا المساء ابدا معك دكتور احمد
الذكاء الاصطناعي انقراض البشريه عنوان
عريض ومخيف واجابته لفريق التاسعه هذا
المساء ايضا كانت مقلقه ما قراءتك برايك
الاجابات اللي اللي سمعتها في التقرير
تبعكم اجاباتي يعني في الصميم لانه في
الرساله اللي وقعتها امس كمان عن تحذير من
مخاطر الذكاء الاصطناعي تتكلم عن المستقبل
تتكلم على انه لما احنا نستخدم الذكاء
الاصطناعي في كل في كل مفاصل الحياه في كل
الاتجاهات صحيحه حيكون له تحكم كامل وممكن
تكون النتائج كارثيه
طيب ماذا عنك يا استاذ رائد هل يجب علينا
ان نوقف عجله الدفع امام الذكاء الاصطناعي
ام لا يمكن ان تتغلب علينا اله نحن
صنعناها كبشر
يعني سؤالك من ثلاث اسئله
الحقيقه مساء الخير لك ولضيفك
لا بدي اجاوبك جواب واحد عن الثلاثه
فعمليا عمليا لا انا اقول انا مع تعليق مع
التعليق لكن لكن كل كل ما يتحدث فيه
المتحدثون من صناع هذه التقنيات او ممن
تدخلوا في هذه التقنيات انا اعتقد انهم
يعلقون الجرس فقط من باب الانذار اذا تركت
هذه الصناعات دون تشريعات تضبطها ودون
قواعد تضبطها ودون سيطره من قبل الدول على
هذه الصناعات انا اعتقد انه نعم سوف نصل
الى مرحله من مراحل الفوضى لكن هذه
الاجراس التي تعلق الان وهذه التصريحات
التي تصدر
لا لا لا لا لا لا لا يمكن ان تنقضي يعني
البشريه في في مامن
لكن لكن قد يكون في هناك اخطاء واذا انت
لاحظتي في التقرير او بما تحدثت في حضرتك
انه دوما انه اذا حدث خطا ما دائما في
التقنيات واحنا بنفهم في التقنيات واي شيء
في برمجه هو قابل للاختراق وقابل لعمليات
التعديل والاضافه فعمليا من الممكن ان
يكون هناك خطا هذا الخطا من الممكن ان
يكون مقصود ومن الممكن ان يكون عمل ارهابي
ومن الممكن ان يكون يعني خطا غير مقصوده
او خطا يتم عن طريق عمل سيبراني واختراق
عمل سيبراني وبالتالي تحدث المشاكل لكن
ليس الى درجه فناء البشريه هذا كلام انا
لا اعتقد انه يعني يجانب الصواب على
الاطلاق دائما هذا كلام يعني غير صحيح الى
جانب النقاط اللي اشرتها خليني انتقل الان
الى دكتور احمد دكتور احمد كيف يمكن ان
نفهم بان الذكاء الاصطناعي الذي طورناه
نحن كبشر يستطيع ان يطور نفسه بنفسه كيف
المحاميين فين القوانين هذا غير القوانين
هذه مش موجوده عندنا فالمحامي اعترف له
انا استخدمت شادي بي تي عشان يعني يديني
معطيات واحثيات الدفاع
يعني الف القوانين من عنده هذا مثل بسيط
على على الحكايه هذه
الان احنا واحنا في المرحله هذه اللي هو
الذكاء العام بنشوف المشاكل هذه تخيل الان
لما نوصل الى السوبر السوبر اللي هو حيكون
مسيطره على جميع مفاصل الحياه بحيث انه
مثلا مرور والمواصلات والاشياء دي
منبع الخوف والرسائل اللي بنسمعها الان
مثل ما تفضل تضيف الكريم انه القضيه ما
فيها انه حتوصل لمرحله يعتبر البشر عباره
عن عقبه في التطور وفي العمليه وفي فاعليه
النظام فحيتخلص منهم طيب في هاي الحاله
وهذه النقاط التي طرحتها دكتور احمد اذهب
الى استاذ رائد يعني صار في ازاحه اليوم
لعدد كبير من الوظائف ومخاوف من ان بعض
الوظائف ستنقرض بفعل فعلا الذكاء
الاصطناعي هل النظم التي طرحتها في بدايه
حديثك والنظم التي تتحدث عنها بعض
الحكومات كافيه لضبط هذه الهلوسه للذكاء
الاصطناعي اليوم
لا هو انا لا اتحدث عن الهلوسه بشكل عام
اتحدث عن المراحل الثلاثه التي تتحدث عنها
الدكتور احمد اللي هي حتى مرحله السوبر
يعني المرحله النهائيه من الذكاء يتعلم
ذاته ويصل الى مرحله الاستغناء عن البشر
في عمليه التعلم ان هذه هذه المرحله اللي
انا اقول انه لا بد من عمليه الضبط ولا بد
من عمليه التشريع ولا بد من ان يكون في
هناك جهات يعني
تضبط عمل هذا الذكاء وتسيطر على مخرجات
هذا الذكاء الاصطناعي
لا لا انا لا اوافق على انه يصل الى مرحله
اباده البشريه ولانه ولكن قد يصل الى
اعمال تخريبيه معينه قد يصل الى كوارث
كبرى نعم صحيح قد يصل لانه الخطا في
الاعتماد الكلي من قبل البشر على تسيير
حياتهم من قبل اله او من قبل ماشين او من
قبل منظومه خوارزميات مبنيه على خوارزميات
معينه من الممكن انها تؤدي الى الى مشاكل
وكوارث لكن لا تصل الى مرحله فناء البشريه
هنا انه يطلع روبوت واللايقات
زينو بالافلام السينمائيه ان الروبوت يعني
من الممكن ان يتمرد في لحظه من اللحظات
على الغباء الانساني وبده يتخلص من البشر
وتتخلص من الانسان هنا انا هذه المرحله
اقول انه فناء البشريه لا يمكن ان يكون
عبر هذه الخوارزميات التي ابتدعاها البشر
والتي اسسها البشر الانسان جبار يا استاذ
نادين والانسان لا يمكن ان يهزم من من
يعني حتى من خوارزميات او من ادوات هو
خلقها بيديه يعني من هالباب هذا كل ما
يجري الان في العالم
يحدث من خلال مسارين متلازمين المسار
الاول التشريع ويجب ضبط هذه المساله
والجانب الاخر السيطره على الصناعات
الخاصه بهذا الذكاء الاصطناعي وبالتالي
يعني شفنا احنا شركه انفيديا وصلت الى
مرحله التريليون دولار في قيمتها السوقيه
من خلال هذه الصناعات وبالتالي المنافس
لهذه الصناعات من مصلحته ان يثير الضجه
ومن مصلحته ان يحدث مثل هذه الجلبه حور
حول هذه التقنيات هذه التقنيات اذا
استخدمت في في امان واستخدمت بحاله صحيحه
وبطريقه صحيحه جدا هي تخدم البشريه بشكل
كبير وسوف تكون يعني خادم للبشريه ونتخطى
فيها امراض ونتخطى فيها علل لطالما يعني
عافت فسادا في البشريه وفي الجسد البشري
طيب الدكتور احمد يعني مقاربه اخيره هل
مازلنا في سياق اطار مقاربه واعيه للذكاء
الاصطناعي حتى لا يفوت الامان الاوام
الوضع اللي احنا فيه وضع مش يعني مش مستقل
والدليل على كذا انه في قمه السبع اللي
حصلت في اليابان كان من ضمن القرارات اللي
صدرت هي حاجه اسمها عمليه هيروشيما اللي
هي بتعمل اطار للتحكم في الذكاء الاصطناعي
وتبادل المعلومات يعني بين الدول بس خليني
اوضح نقطه صغيره يا اختي الكريمه نحن
نتكلم على ضوابط ونتكلم على انه الذكاء
الاصطناعي لازم يكون له نوع من التحكم
الوقود تبع الذكاء الاصطناعي هو المعلومات
فالتحكم يسير عن طريق المعلومات المعلومات
الاكثر اللي انت بتغذيها للذكاء الاصطناعي
حيكون اذكى واذكى واذكى
ثلاثه وخمسه وسبعين مليار معلومه اربعه
يعني تريليون معلومه فانت لما تتجاوز حدود
معين معلومات يصبح عنده نوع من
الاستقلاليه وهذا اللي احنا المفروض انه
نضبط فيه عمليه يعني عمل الذكاء الاصطناعي
شكرا
جزيلا المعلومات شكرا
حذر تقرير لمجله البريطانيه من تبعات
التشريعات التي اقرتها دول حول العالم تحت
ذريعه حمايه المستخدمين من المحتوى الضار
والمعلومات المضلله على شبكات تواصل
اجتماعي
على الانترنت الذي تمت صياغته بعد انتحار
مراهق يبلغ 14 عاما بعد ان شاهد مواد على
الانترنت وتشير المجله الى ان البرازيل
اقرت قانون الاخبار الكاذبه الذي يعاقب
الشبكات الاجتماعيه لفشلها في تحديد
المعلومات المضلله كما ستعلن الهند عن
مشروع قانون تنظيم الانترنت في يونيو الذي
يقال انه سيحمل المنصات الاجتماعيه
مسؤوليه محتوى المستخدمين
المثير للقلق ان هذه التحركات تلهم
الحكومات في الاجزاء الاقل ديمقراطيه من
العالم لصياغه قواعد جديده خاصه بها
[موسيقى]
قال الرئيس الفرنسي من هي المكروه ان
سلطات كوسوفو تتحمل مسؤوليه الاضطرابات
التي تصاعدت منذ تولي رؤساء البلديات
المنحدرين من اصلا الالباني مهامهم في
المنطقه ذات الاغلبيه الصربيه شمال البلاد
لقد اوضحنا لسلطات كوسوفو انه كان من
الخطا المضي في انتخابات من هذا النوع
سالتقي مع المستشار الالماني اولافشولت
ورئيسي كوسوفو وصربيا كما فعلنا في اجتماع
براك لكن من الواضح جدا ان السلطات
الكوسوفيه تتحمل بعض المسؤوليه عن الوضع
الحالي وكان هناك عدم احترام لاتفاق مهم
تم التوقيع عليه قبل اسبوعين فقط
اسرعوا بين كوسوفو وصربيا ليس وليد اليوم
في شمال كوسوفو تتكرر المواجهات بين سلطات
والاقليه الصربيه المدعومه من بلغراد
الغرب يقول ان روسيا تدفع الاوضاع للتصعيد
وقوفها الى جانب صربيا
[موسيقى]
بؤره جديده قديمه للتوتر في اوروبا مواجهه
بجذور تاريخيه ضاربه في الماضي بين
الكوسوفو وصربيا صراع بلغه التاريخ
والجغرافيا الحكايه تعود الى سنوات خلت
كوسوفو التي اعلنت استقلالها عن صربيا عام
2008 تشهد مواجهات متكرره في شمالها حيث
تشجع بيلغراد الصرب على تحدي السلطات
الساعيه لفرض سيادتها على المنطقه باكملها
كوسوفو دوله معترف بها جزئيا تقع في جنوب
شرقي اوروبا تبلغ مساحتها نحو 11 الف كيلو
متر مربع فيما يبلغ عدد سكانها مليون و
800 الف نسمه من ضمنهم 120 الف صربي اما
اغلبيتهم الساحقه فمن الالبان المنطقه
شهدت احداثا دمويه
البانوكوسوفو تعرض لهجمات متتاليه من قبل
الصرب كان اعنفها في العام 19
حينها شنت قوه الناتو هجوما على
يوغوسلافيا استمر 78 يوما لتنتهي الحرب
بعد انسحاب القوات الصربيه ومنذ ذلك الوقت
تعمل قوات تابعه للحلف على حفظ السلام
هناك اصابع الاتهام الغربيه تشير الى
روسيا وتتهمها بدفع الوضع نحو التصعيد من
اجل الضغط على اوروبا الكرملين اعلنها
صراحه وقال ان موسكو تؤيد صربيا وحقوق
صربي كوسوفو بشكل كامل وغير مشروط
التوترات تتزايد يوما بعد يوم وحدتها وصلت
الى اعلان الرئيس الصربي الكسندر وضع جيش
بلاده في حاله تاهب قصوى مع تحرك وحداته
نحو الحدود القريبه مع كوسوفو مشاهد تعود
الى الاذهان صور النزاع العنيف في المنطقه
قبل اكثر من عقدين من الزمن بلال البشتين
العربيه
واردا على اتهامات الغرب لروسيا باذكاء
الصراع في كوسوفو قال المتحدث باسم كريم
اننا نراقب الوضع وندعم صربيا والصرب بشكل
مطلق وغير مشروط نعتقد انه يجب احترام
جميع الحقوق والمصالح المشروعه لسرب
كوسوفو وضمنها ولا ينبغي ان يكون هناك
مكان لنوع من الاعمال الاستفزازيه التي
تنتهك حقوق الصرب بالطبع نتابع التطورات
عن كسب وقلقون بشان ذلك
نذهب الان الى موسكو معنا من هناك
السياسي سيده متري اهلا بك معنا في
التاسعه هذا المساء هل تريد روسيا
المستنزفه من الحرب تشتيت انظار الغرب
وفتح جبهه جديده لصرف النظر عن اوكرانيا
تحياتي لكم الاستاذه المشاهدين بكل تاكيد
لدى روسيا تاثير على كوسوفو على صربيا
اولا الكنيسه الروتوكسيه الروسيه لها
تاثير على الصرب على كورسوفو وايضا في
السابق نتذكر ان هناك كره للحلف الشمال
الاطلسي لدى الصرب بسبب اعتداء على عمل
1999 وروسيا تقف الان بجانب الصرب لان
هناك موقف يعني متقارب بين الصرب والروس
بكثير من الملفات السياسيه وكما قلت ايضا
الكنيسه
الروسيه لها تاثير على الصرب ويربط الدين
المسيحي الشعبين الروسي هذا التاثير
الديني له تاثير على الصراع مرات السؤال
الاول
بان من صربيا افتعال هذا التوتر من جديد
يعني حتى تتحول الانظار عن اوكرانيا
والحرب الروسيه
المشهد صربيا مراقبون يتصورون من صربيا قد
تلجا المساعده وتطلب للمساعده من روسيا في
حال اندلاع حرب محتمله هل روسيا جاهزه
لفتح جبهتين وبالتالي معركه مباشره مع
النيتو
حتى الان لم يصدر اي تصريحات رسميه اذا
هذا الملف ولكن
حذر بان يحدث لك انفجار كبير في قلب
اوروبا بسبب ملف كوسوفو وبان هذا الشيء هو
بسبب سياسات الحلف الشمال الاطلس الخاطئ
في 1999 وتاثير هذه السياسات على المنطقه
بكل تاكيد الان روسيا وهذا الملف له نوع
من الضغط هذا نوع من الضغط على الاتحاد
الاوروبي وعلى حلف الشمال الاطلسي ولذلك
روسيا تدخل في هذه في هذا الملف وتحاول
التقرب من صربيا كون صربيا لها يعني تاثير
كبير على السياسات الاوروبيه وسربه حتى
الان يعني رايها مختلف عن راي الدول
الاوروبيه تجاه الملف الاوكراني وحتى
تجاهل الملفات المختلفه الاخرى وهي قريبه
من روسيا في كثير من الملفات السياسيه
ولذلك الان روسيا تحاول الضغط عبر هذا
الملف على حلف الشمال الاطلسي ودول
الاتحاد الاوروبي وتعتبره من اوليات
اولويات الان في هذا الوقت للضغط بسبب
الضغوطات التي تمارس ضد روسيا في من قبل
الاتحاد الاوروبي واحد في الشمال الاطلسي
شكرا جزيلا لك من
محلل السياسي
[موسيقى]
التاسعه هذا المساء مستمره ونتابع في
سياقها ولكن بعد قليل
وكاله الطاقه تقول ان مخزونه ايران من
اليورينيوم يتجاوز 23 مره الحد المسموح
[موسيقى]
مستمرون معكم في التاسعه هذا المساء وفي
تفاصيلها قالت الوكاله الدوليه للطاقه
التداريه في تقرير الدوري ان ايران تواصل
انتهاك القيود المفروضه على برنامجها
النووي اكدت الوكاله ان طهران سمحت لها
بتركيب اجهزه مراقبه بموقعين معلنين
للتخصيب وهي بانتظار التعاون الايراني
لتركيب كاميرات مراقبه بجميع المواقع
النوويه اشارت الوكاله الدوليه للطاقه الى
ان ايران قدمت شرحا لاثار اليورينيوم التي
وجدت باحد المواقع والا اسئله لها بعد ان
اوضح الطهران وجود اثار يورنيوم باحد
المواقع كما قالت الوكاله ان مخزون ايران
من اليورينيوم يتجاوز 23 مره الحد المسموح
لها
قبل ذلك كشف موقع اكسيوس الاخباري عن مساء
تبذلها اداره الرئيس الامريكي جو بايدن
للتواصل مع ايران عبر سلطنه عمان بشان
برنامج طهران نووي ونقل الموقع عن مسؤولين
امريكيين واسرائيليين القول ان كبيره
مستشاري بايدن سافر الى عمان اوائل مايو
لبحث حل دبلوماسيا مع ايران وقال مسؤول
اسرائيلي كبير لاكسيوس ان مسؤولين عمانيين
يجرون محادثات غير مباشره بين واشنطن
وطهران مضيفا بان طهران ارسلت اشارات
لواشنطن استعدادها لتقييد البرنامج النووي
في المرحله المقبله واشار ايضا الى قلق
رئيس الوزراء الاسرائيلي بنيامين نتنياهو
من وساع واشنطن لابرام اتفاق محتمل مع
ايران جاته اكد مسؤولون امريكي لاكسيوس
بانه واشنطن لا تتفاوض مع ايران على اتفاق
مؤقت او تخفيف العقوبات
[موسيقى]
في اخبار السودان لا يزال السودان يا انه
تحت وطاه اقتتال يابى ان ينتهي فبعد
تفاؤلا ساد الخرطوم الايام الفائته
بالتزام طرفي الصراع بهدنه قد تقود وقتها
لوقت لوقف دائما للنار عاد القصف المدفع
ليقطع احلام السودانيين في ام درمان الجيش
السوداني علق مشاركته في مفاوضات جده دون
الانسحاب منها مبررا قراره بعدم التزام
قوات الدعم السريع ببنود الهدنه وانه لا
معنى الاستمرار في تمديدها
الخارجيه السودانيه قالت ان قوات دعم
السريع استغلت الهدنه لشن الهجمات وسعت
لادخال اسلحه ومقاتلين لمناطق عده في
العاصمه وخارجها الطيران الحرب عاد
للتحليق في سماء الخرطوم بعد الشبكات سادت
منطقه المهندسين في ام درمان ساحه
المواجهات بين الجيش والدعم السريع اتسعت
مجددا خارج العاصمه حيث نشر الجيش
السوداني مقطعا مصورا لقواته في مدينه
الاوبيض في ولايه شمال كردوفان مؤكدا انه
تصدى لهجوما من قوات دعم السريع على
المدينه
[موسيقى]
الان نذهب الى الخرطوم ومعنا هناك الصحفي
عمار ابو شيبه عمار اهلا بك معنا في
التاسعه هذا المساء كيف انعكس اعلان الجيش
تعليق المفاوضات على الوضع الميداني في
السودان
اهلا بك نادين واهلا بالمشاهدين الكرام
نعم منذ صباح الباكر نادين عده اشتباكات
دارت هنا في العاصمه الخرطوم خاصه الجنوبي
العاصمه الخرطوم هذه المناطق التي تشهد
عده اشتباكات منذ عده ايام ولكن دخلت هذه
الاشتباكات حيز العنف بشكل واضح خاصه في
منطقه محليه جبل اولياء وفي معسكر الطيبه
وهذا المعسكر الذي دائما ما كان يقصد
بالطيران وترد من خلال قوات الدعم السريع
بالمضادات الارضيه حسب المعلومات
الميدانيه الوارده من هناك واشارات عسكريه
عديده لان المعارك استمرت حتى دخلت الى
قلب العاصمه الخرطوم في منطقه السوق
العربي والمنطقه الاستراتيجيه وهذه
المنطقه التي بثت من خلالها عده فيديوهات
للدعم السريعه اعلن من خلالها السيطره
الكامله على هذه المنطقه التي تجاور جسر
الفتحاب والذي يربط ما بين المدينه
الخرطوم واندرمان وهذه المنطقه ايضا
تتواجد فيها عده منشات ومقار مهمه جدا
كمصنع صك العمله وايضا عدد من المقرات
الطبيه الاخرى والعسكريه في مدينه بحري تم
الاستماع الى دبي انفجارات في شمال
المدينه في منطقه القدر وفي احياء
الحلفايه ايضا في مدينه ام درمان عده
اشتباكات دارت في احياء المورده والعباسيه
حيث تحدثنا الى عدد من المواطنون والشهود
العيان الذين اشاهدوا الى ان هنالك
اشتباكات تدور بين فتره واخرى وفي محيط
الاذاعه والتلفزيون ايضا
الصراع العسكري اكثر فاكثر يصبح اكثر
دمويه مع تعليق المفاوضات
نعم بيان الجيش الاخير بعد التعليق كان قد
اشار الى ان عدم التزام الدعم السريع هو
ما دفعه لي تعليق الهدنه وبالامس واول امس
وحتى من الايام الاولى لتوقيع الهدنه كنا
نرى ونشاهد ونوثق هذه الاشتباكات العنيفه
جدا ما يعني ان المعارك تحتدم بين فتره
واخرى وتعود مره اخرى بالجانب الاخر قوات
الدعم السريع تتحدث بان الجيش شن عدد من
القارات الجويه على عدد من مناطقها ما
يعني من خلال البيان البيانيين ان هنالك
عمليات عسكريه تدور رغم التوقيع على
الهدنه ولكن هنا السؤال ايضا كيف سيكون
الحال بعد التعليق هل سترجع المعارك الى
ذلك العنف الاول الذي كنا نشهده بكثافه
طوال اليوم بحسب خبراء عسكريين يشيرون الى
ان محاولات المسهلين الى الوصول الى عمليه
تهدئه جديده قد في ان لا تصل القوات
المتقاتله على الارض الى هذه النقطه ولكن
مع هذا يزداد الوضع الوضع الانساني سوءا
نادين بشكل واضح وكبير سواء هنا في
العاصمه الخرطوم او في مدينه بحري او
مدينه ام درمان او حتى عدد من الولايات
التي تدور حول اطرافها عدد من الاشتباكات
مثلا ولايه شمال كردفان وعاصمتها الابيض
تدور فيها عده اشتباكات ولايات دارفور
ايضا كذلك فيها عده اشتباكات مع كل هذا
يزداد الوضع سوءا ويتازم اكثر مما هو عليه
هنا في شرق العاصمه هنالك عده مستشفيات
تعمل تمديد حضرتك حتى منتصف شهر يونيو
اكتفي معك بهذا القدر عمار
الصحفي عمار ابو شيبه شكرا لك
[موسيقى]
خطط المعارضين لصفقه بايدن مكارتي
المتعلقه بسقف الدين فشلت في اخماد مشروع
القانون في مهده فتشريع اجتاز عقبه مهمه
بعد اقراره من قبل لجنه القواعد بواقع
سبعه اصوات مقابل سته لجنه القواعد ارسلت
تشريع الى مجلس النواب بكامل هيئته لبحثي
والتصويت عليه اليوم واذا ما اقره مجلس
النواب الذي يسيطر عليه الجمهوريون
فسيحيله الى مجلس الشيوخ لبحثه والتصويت
عليه ايضا مشروع القانون يقضي بتعليق سقف
الدين البالغ
31.4 تريليون دولار حتى اول يناير 2025
كما يضع حدا لبعض الانفاق الحكومي على
مدار العامين المقبلين يسرع عمليه
الموافقه على بعض مشروعات الطاقه ويعيد
اموال مكافحه كورونا غير المستخدمه يتعين
ان يقر الكونغرس بمجلسي هذا التشريع قبل
الخامس من يونيو حينها قد تعجز الولايات
المتحده عن سداد ديونها لاول مره في
تاريخها
[موسيقى]
نذهب الان الى احسن الطوب مراسل العربيه
من واشنطن حسين اهلا بك معنا في التاسعه
هذا المساء طالما ان الكونجرس في سباق مع
الزمن لاقرار اتفاق سقف الدين ما المنتظر
اليوم من الجلسه العامه
تحيه لك نادين الانظار تتجه الى قاعه مجلس
النواب الذي بدا الاجتماع منذ اربعين
دقيقه تقريبا وبعد نحو ساعه من الان سيصوت
على قاعده نقاش هذا التشريع طبعا اليوم هو
الامتحان الثاني بعد العقبه التي اجتادها
اشتد التشريع البارحه من لجنه القواعد في
مجلس النواب من المتوقع ان يمر اليوم
قبل مقار في وقاده
الحزبين في مجلس النوابه متفائلون كما
يقولون بان لديهم الاصوات الكافيه وان
اعلن نحو 30 نائبا جمهوريا من اليمين
الجمهوري معارضتهم وبانهم سيصوتون ضد هذا
التشريع الا ان مجلس النواب على ما يبدو
لديها الاصوات الكافيه من ليعوض
الجمهوريين من قبل الديمقراطيين المعتدلين
الذين قالوا انهم سيصوتون لصالح هذا
التشريع حكيم يفرز
على الاقليه الديمقراطيه في مجلس النواب
تحدث اليوم وقال بانها هي اولويه لمكه بان
يؤمن ثلثي اصوات اعضاء تجمعه الجمهوري
الديمقراطيون يضعون المسؤوليه على عاتق في
حال اقر اليوم متى سيتم التصويت في مجلس
الشيوخ لاحقا حتى يمكن القول بين الكونغرس
حينها انهى قضيه سداد الديون
زعيم الديمقراطيين في مجلس الشيوخ قال
بانه عندما يستلم
التشريع اذا مرر اليوم سيكون التصويت يوم
السبت واذا احتاجوا سيصوتون خلال عطله
نهايه الاسبوع اي عفوا سيستلم سيكون
التصويت في المجلس الشيوخ يوم الجمعه واذا
احتاجوا لمزيد من الوقت سيصوتون السبت
والاحد المهم ان يمرروه باسرع وقت ممكن
لكي يتجنبوا ان تعجز الولايات المتحده عن
سداد ديونها هناك اصرار في مجلس الشيوخ
ايضا على تمرير هذا التشريع باسرع وقت
ممكن عند حتى بالنسبه لزعيم الجمهوريين
مثل ما قلنا الذي يقال انه استطاع ان يقنع
ما بين 10 الى 20 عضوا جمهوريا في المجلس
ليساندوا الديمقراطيين على التصويت لصالح
هذا المشروع بالنسبه للاعضاء الديمقراطيين
في مجلس الشيوخ هناك اكثر من 40 عضوا
مستعدون للتصويت لصالح المشروع ما يعني
انهم قد يحتاجون الى 10 الى ما بين 10
وعشرين عضوا جمهوريا وهم لدى طبعا حتى في
مجلس الشيوخ هناك معارضه من الجمهوريين
ايضا هناك معارضين الذي قال بانه لن يصوت
ضده وما حجم المعارضين من محافظين وحتى
تقدميين لهكذا تسويه او صفقه مالي ازمه
سقف الدين
ان كنا نتحدث عن مجلس النواب هناك 30
جمهوريا معارضا وعدد بحدود العشره او 15
ديمقراطيه معارضا لهذا التشريع عندما
نتحدث عن مجلس مجلس الشيوخ هناك تقريبا
عشره ديمقراطيين يعارضون هذا المشروع ولكن
لديها نسبه كبيره من المؤيدين من
الجمهوريين حتى الان منعرفه بالجمهوريين
هناك تقريبا عشره جمهوريين يرفضونه برفضا
تاما ويقولون بانهم سيصوتون
وهناك من يتعهد بان يستخدم كل اجراء لديه
لتعطيل تمرير هذا المشروع ولكن الامر طبعا
في نهايه المطاف مرتبط بالاغلبيه حتى لو
استطاع ان يعطل اذا كان زعيم الجمهوريين
يؤيد ذلك وزعيم الديمقراطيين يؤيد ذلك
فستكون العقبات سيذللون العقبات امام هذا
المشروع يبدو ان زعماء الكونغرس لديهم
الامكان الاصوات الكافيه لتمرين هذا
التشريع ان كان في مجلس النواب اليوم
والتصويت سيكون على الساعه 8:30 بتوقيت
واشنطن او
يمررون بعد ذلك في مجلس الشيوخ يوم الجمعه
او حتى تضطر كما قلنا السبت او الاحد
ولديهم الاصوات الكافيه ليمرروا يمررونها
هناك حسين التوت مراسل العربيه من واشنطن
شكرا لك
هذا المساء مستمره ونتابع في سياقه ولكن
بعد قليل
التي اسقطت حصانه موسكو
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم خروقات متعدده كسرت ما وصف
بحصانه موسكو فالمدينه التي اشبه بثكنه
عسكريه عكرت اجوائها مؤخرا مسيرات
اوكرانيه عده وصادت بعض زواياها رسائل عده
حملها الهجوم بالمسيرات على موسكو اولها
دخول المعارك مرحله الحرب النفسيه
وتكتيكات توازن الرعب لكشف نقاط ضعف الخصم
كما يقول الخبراء روسيا اتهمت الجانب
الاوكراني بالهجوم على مناطق مدنيه في
عاصمتها مضيفه ان اوكرانيا تتعمد
الاستفزاز وتحاول ترهيب الروس كيف من
جهتها نفت التورط في الحادث مكرره اتباع
سياسه الغموض الاستراتيجي بشان ضرب العمق
الروسي هذه الاختراقات دفعت بضباط روسي
السابقين لتاكيد ضروره انشاء روسيا لانظمه
تمكنها من رؤيه طائرات المسيره على
ارتفاعات منخفضه للغايه لكن مساحه روسيا
الكبيره قد تخلق ثغرات دائما هذا ورجح
خبراء عسكريون اوكرانيون اتمام الهجوم
الاوكراني المحتمل الاخير بطائرات من دون
طيار من طراز
علما بان موسكو تقع على بعد حوالي 500
كيلومتر من الحدود مع اوكرانيا
[موسيقى]
طائره اوكرانيا البصيره
اسند اليها دور الوصول لقلب العاصمه روسيه
موسكو او على الاقل كانت سلاح الاكثر
ترجيحا ما هي هذه الطائرات بدون طيار وهل
تستطيع فعلا الوصول الى موسكو وما وراءها
كما يجادل العسكريون اوكرانيون اذا مسيرات
اعتمدها الجيش الاوكراني عام 2020 لكنها
لم تدخل الخدمه على ما يبدو قبل عام 2022
هذه المسيرات التي يتم انتاجها في
اوكرانيا يبلغ مداح حوالي 800 كم هي
متعدده المهام بما في ذلك الهجوم
والاستطلاع وعمليات البحث وحتى الانقاذ
تعمل ليلا نهارا وفي جميع الظروف الجويه
وحتى سيئه منها يمكنها الطيران لسبع ساعات
متواصله على ارتفاع سته كيلو مترات اما
سرعتها فتتراوح ما بين 160 كيلومترا في
الساعه فهي مسيرات قادره على استي
ملازمتها 20 كيلوغراما من الذخائر وبينها
قنابل جويه غير موجهه من عيار اثنين
مليمترا تمتلك نظام طيار الي يتيح لها
بالتحليق بدون حتى اشاره جي بي اس هذه
المسيرات نشطت في سماء موسكو مؤخرا
واقتربت منها في مناسبات عده بين هجوم على
مدينه كولومنا في ضواحي العاصمه
[موسيقى]
كاسحه جليدا جديده تعمل روسيا على تطويرها
متخصصه بالدعم والامداد البحري حيث اعلنت
شركه الروسيه المتحده لبناء السفن العمل
على مشروع تصنيع سفينه
الشركه اكدت البدء بتركيب المحركات على
هذه السفينه مضيفه ان المحرك الرئيسي يزن
60 طنا وسيساعد على القيام برحلات بحريه
طويله بشكل موثوق وبالتالي امداد السفن
الروسيه الاخرى بالوقود والوظائع يبلغ طول
كل سفينه 130 مترا وعرضها 21 مترا وتستوعب
طاقما مؤلفا من 24 شخصا تتميز سفن الامداد
التي تطورها روسيا بهياكل متينه تمكنها من
الابحار في المياه المتجمده وقطع تسعه
الاف ميل بحري في كل مهمه
من السجون لمنصات التواصل فاجنر تتفنن في
تجنيد المقاتلين خاصه وانها مقبله على
استحقاقات جديده في اوكرانيا خلال الايام
المقبله فبعد استراحه قصيره من مفرمه
اللحم التي تعرضت لها في بخموت بعد سحب
المساجين من سجونهم بدات المجموعه بالتوجه
نحو فيسبوك وتويتر ونشر الالاف الاعلانات
من اجل تجنيد اطباء ومشغلي طائرات بدون
طيار وحتى علماء نفس للمساعده في العمليات
القتاليه تنوعت اللغات التي اعتمدتها
فاجنر لتجد المقاتلين فاستخدمت الفرنسيه
مرورا بالفيتيرميه وصولا الى الاسبانيه
طبعا عرضت رواتب مغريه تصل الى 2800 دولار
شهريا ورعايه صحيه ونشرت ارقام هواتف
وحسابات على تيليجرام للتواصل
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
قفزت بالشركات الامنيه مجددا الى واجهه
الاحداث العالميه مطرحه تساؤلات حول الدور
الذي تلعبه هذه الشركات وما اذا كنا نتجه
نحو خصخصه الحروب الشركات الامنيه
والعسكريه وان ظهرت لاول مره بعد الحرب
العالميه الثانيه الى ان جذورها قديمه
مرتبطه بعصابات المرتزقه التي يدفع لها
المال مقابل القيام بعمليات عسكريه لكن
صفه الارتزاق ذات المدلول البشع يتم اليوم
اعاده تجميلها نحت مسميات جديده ذات طبيعه
تجاريه مقابل خدمه امنيه او عسكريه وما
زال الجدل قائما بشان قانونيتها اول ظهور
لشركه امنيه في العالم كان بالولايات
المتحده في عام
1946 اسسها محاربون قدامه واطلقوا عليها
اسماء داينكورب غير ان شهره الشركات
الامنيه برزت بعد احتلال العراق في عام
2003 ودوره في حمايه شخصيات ومنشات مدنيه
وعسكريه مقابل عقود بالمليارات دفعتها
الاداره الامريكيه حينها لهذه الشركات على
غرار بلاك ووتر الا ان سمعه بلاك ووتر
تشوهت بعد ارتكابها لمجازر وتجاوزات في حق
مدنيين عزل على غرار مجزره النسور في
بغداد في عام 2007
[موسيقى]
اهم الاسباب التي تلجا فيها بعض الدول الى
الشركات الامنيه والعسكريه انها لا تحتكم
لضوابط القانون الدولي وبالتالي يمكن
التبرا منها في حال تورطت في جرائم حرب
عندما قصف الجيش الامريكي عناصر فاجنر في
سوريا قتل العشرات منهم تبرات روسيا منهم
والا كانت ستجبر على الرد ومواجهه
الولايات المتحده كما ان الشركات الامنيه
والعسكريه يقودها عاده ضباط محترفون خارج
الخدمه يتميزون بكفاءه عاليه في اداء
المهام الموكله لهم ومتحررون من القيود
البيروقراطيه التي تميز الجيوش النظاميه
من الانتقادات التي توجه الى الشركات
الامنيه ان عناصرها يتبعون صاحب الشركه
وليس الدوله ولا يحكمهم قانون عسكري ولا
تدرج في الرتب ما يجعل السيطره عليهم امرا
ليس سهلا
[موسيقى]
نهبوا مستشفيات وتدميرها احتجاز اطباء
ومنعهم من علاج المرضى لائحه اتهام طويله
سقطها منظمه الصحه العالميه لروسيا فالدب
روسي نفث غضبه خلال اشهر من الحرب
باتجاهات اوكرانيه عده بينها القطاع الصحي
منظمه الصحه العالميه رصدت الف هجوم
الروسي ضد المستشفيات والمراكز الصحيه
والاطباء في اوكرانيا منذ بدء العمليه
العسكريه واسفلت تلك الهجمات عن مقتل نحو
100 شخص بينهم عاملون في الحقل الطبي
ومرضى وفق صحيفه تيليجراف البريطانيه
الصحه العالميه وصفت هذه الهجمات بجريمه
حرب وانتهاك القانون الانساني الدولي
مصنفه هذا العدد بالاعلى على الاطلاق في
ظل الاعلان عن حاله طوارئ انسانيه اما اهم
مناطق توزع هذه الاعتداءات فهي خرسون
حيث حضرت منظمه الصحه العالميه من زياده
الوفيات وتدهور النظام الصحي على الماده
الطويل اذا تواصلت الهجمات ضد المنشات
الطبيه لسيما تاثير الهجمات النفسي على
المرضى سوف يجعلهم يخشون فكره طلب
المساعده لسنوات
[موسيقى]
اشار التقديرات الى ان الزعيم الكوري
الشمالي كيم جونغ اون يعاني من اضطرابات
في النوم يبلغ وزنه حوالي 140 كيلوغراما
بحسب وكاله الاستخبارات الكوريه الجنوبيه
استخبارات كوريا الجنوبيه تكشف معلومات
جديده عن صحه زعيم كوريا الشماليه
سمنه زائده وارق
140 كلغ وزن زعيم كوريا الشماليه وهو
يعاني من اضطرابات في النوم
الكحول والنيكوتين تسبب بالارق للزعيم
كشفه سواد الجفون تحت عينيه
[موسيقى]
استخبارات كوريا الجنوبيه كشفت ظهور خدوش
وكدمات باستمرار على يدي وذراعيكم يشير
الى التهاب الجلد كدليل على الاجهاد
استخبارات الصول اعتمدت على الذكاء
الاصطناعي للكشف عن الوضع الصحي لزعيم
كوريا الشماليه
بمجرد تحليل صوره الاخيره
زوبعه العواصف التي يسببها الملياردير
ايلون ماسك هبت هذه المره من الصين لتثير
تساؤلات واشنطن ان لم يكن استفزازها حيث
بحث ملك تسلا مع وزير الصناعه الصيني سبل
تطوير مركبات تعمل بطاقه جديده وسيارات
ذكيه متصله اللقاء لم تتكشف تفاصيله بعد
لكنه دفع رئيس الامريكي جو بايدن لتصريح
بان علاقات ماسك ببعض الدول الاجنبيه
باتستحق الدراسه من جهتها اكدت الخارجيه
الصينيه ابداء ماسك لرغبه مجموعته في
مواصله تطوير انشطتها في الصين علما بان
تسلا اعربت في ايبل الماضي عن نيتها انشاء
مصنع ضخم ثاني للبطاريات في شنغهاي بطاقه
اوليه تبلغ 10,000 بطاريه سنويا
السنه لها تواصل التهامها لكل ما تصادفه
في كندا حيث خرجت الحرائق عن السيطره
ممتده على مساحه تزيد على 100 كم مربع
وتسببت في تدمير مباني عده كما اجبرت اكثر
من 16 الف شخص على اخلاء منازلهم بسبب
الحراره القياسيه
[موسيقى]
في نهايه التاسع هذا المساء لم يبقى الا
ان نذكر بعناوينها
جذور الصراع في كوسوفو تنبت من جديد الغرب
يتهم روسيا بافتعال حرب جديده في اوروبا
وماجد
الحمد لله بكل الامن وامان والان في بعض
شائعات وفاته الدعم السريع يؤكد ان قائده
محمد حمدان دقله بخير ويقاتل في صفوف
الاولى
روبوت
صفقه بايضه لسقف الدين تتجاوز مخططات
التعطيل وتتحضر لاختبارها الاخير امام
الكونجرس
بعد تحضيرات الخبراء من خطورته الذكاء
الاصطناعي يجيب فريق التاسع هذا المساء عن
سيناريوهات انقراض البشر بسببه
التاسع هذا المساء انتهت ولكن اخبرنا
بالتاكيد مستمره بعد قليل الزميل طاهر
بركه 360 ساعه اخباريه مختلفه ماذا في
جعبتكم اليوم يا طاهر يسعد هالمسا يسعد
مساكينا سنناقش طبعا بالمزيد من التفصيل
تداعيات استهداف العمق الروسي من قبل
اوكرانيا في موضوع اخر مهم ايضا تعرضت الى
بعض
تفاصيله نبحث من زوايا اخرى التصعيد
الصربي الكوسوفي الجديد يعني بعد نحو ربع
قرن على انتهاء حرب شهدت اعنف المجازر في
البلقان ونتابع ايضا ماذا تعني تصريحات
جروسسي بالامس بان الحظ وحده هو الذي يمنع
حصول كارثه نوويه
كوني معا متابعه طيب
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات